you are here somewhere I can't see you
it's too far away but you're here
somewhere maybe here maybe here you
could be almost anywhere here but you're
definitely here you don't know why or
for what
no one does all you know all I know is
that you are somewhere here magnetized
the strange lushly coated wet rock
floating in its designated position of
endless nothing this rock you are on
it's tiny and you are tiny compared to
this rock if we zoom out a little bit
look how tiny you are even further
tinier you're so tiny
you're even tiny your brain can't
comprehend how tiny you are your tiny
self is posted up on this tiny rock
surrounded by this dark massive unending
space that could be anything and nothing
at the same time this rock will give you
life it will give you everything you
need to live on its crust for a period
of time it might feel like a while or it
might feel like no time at all depending
on what mood you're in when you consider
this idea regardless of how it feels to
you when compared to almost everything
else it will be so so short a single
frame in a movie that never ends a frame
that could be removed and nothing would
really change about the movie in this
frame you will live on this rock then
you will die and you'll have no idea
what happened
no one will if you're really lucky
you'll have some friends and family and
lovers who will be sad for a little
while they'll miss you but they'll try
really hard not to because being sad and
missing someone all the time it's really
tiresome it'll mess up their lives so
they'll try to work through it and move
on as best they can they might go to
therapy they might practice techniques
to get through grieving they'll probably
be somewhat successful they will also
die if you're even more unusually lucky
you'll be missed and remembered for a
little bit longer by a few more people
perhaps you did something that impacted
more people while you lived on this rock
perhaps you were profoundly artistic or
smart or a leader or an inventor when
you die perhaps more people will be sad
for a little longer stretch of time most
of these people would have never really
known you though so they won't think
about you too much for too long either
and when they do it'll mostly be a
misconstruction of you based on their
own ideals they will all die over time
every person every memory of a person
will all die with each other
won't matter to you to mean to anyone
we'll all be dead the things you did the
words you said the impacts you made for
good or for bad big or small they will
all lose your nametag and will not
matter to anyone or anything so whatever
you're nervous about right now whoever
you're nervous because of perhaps a
first date a job interview a big
presentation an important test a hard
conversation you might feel paralyzed
with anxiety you might feel like the
course of your life is hinged on this
coming moment that the fate of reality
is on your shoulders it's not you might
be worried that you're going to do the
wrong thing or fail you might but
everything will be okay because for some
reason against all conceivable odds
you're on this weird rock this planet
that births life life that births more
life novel life intelligent life you in
this unknowable vacuum of potential
nihility you have this playground this
consciousness this capacity for wonder
emotion and thought the only real
mistake you can make is to not recognize
this to never relax and enjoy the
hilarious and enthralling absurdity of
it all to realize that it all means
nothing beyond itself and to find
freedom and inspiration in this thought
to explore and connect with what it can
mean to be a you on a rock in a solar
system in a galaxy in a universe in a
who knows what to be kind and decent to
have fun to love to laugh to cry to try
to fail to live and to remember that no
matter whatever happens you can still do
all of this no matter what you do in
life worst case is you try your best you
be yourself and you do what you can do
with compassion honesty effort and
understanding and it goes worst case and
then you move on like everything else
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder